Hello,
Dr. Peterson.
Do you ever fear that your psychological reading of the Bible is wrong?
While I'm sure it's wrong in some ways,
even Satan can use scripture for his own purpose.
What if you're just using the word for your own gate?
Well,
then God helped me.
I guess that's,
that's what I would say.
What if I'm just using the word for my own gain?
I guess it would depend on what you think of his game.
I am using it for my own gain,
but I would say that I've aligned my own game with the gain of others and that's
made my own game.
It's a weird thing,
right?
Because if I'm see that way I can have my cake and eat it too.
I can do what I think is best for me,
but at the same time,
I can do what is best for others.
And I've also defined what is best for me as what is simile Tamia Asley best for
others.
And I believe that.
I truly believe that.
I think I'm fully convinced of that because I've thought it through,
so,
okay.
That's my answer to that.